For the grace of God offers salvation
to all people teaching us
to live Godly life.
Jesus gave himself for us to redeem us and to
purify for himself a people that
are his very own.
So as I said earlier any true movement of
God will be directly tied to his Spirit working through
his word.
It's not just emotionalism. It's not just some
manipulation it is that and so
I want to spend some time.
Explaining some scripture to us.
From God's word. It's gonna lead us to see God
rightly and see ourselves in light of it.
Which we've been praying it leads to both Brokenness and
repentance and encouragement that we
can pursue him.
As you'll see in God set this all up.
with a really interesting Passage
as we continue through our Series in Titus a text
of scripture that deals directly with sin and our
response.
And so if you're not there already go ahead and turn to Titus
Chapter 3 with me in God's
word Titus 3.
We are almost to the end of Titus. In fact next Sunday will
be the last sermon in this series of
Titus.
in case you know need to know that but
Before we get into the text today. I want to make something abundantly
clear.
The subject we're talking about today, which many people
commonly refer to as church discipline.
It this is never meant to be punitive.
Never meant to be vindictive.
Never meant to be used as a club.
to beat someone up with
the goal in all this is not to kick people out of the church.
That's what it's been characterized as before the goal actually.
Now you see how all this ties together as we go through this the goal
is actually holiness.
The goal is Godly living.
for his church
The goal is Imaging Jesus to the world around us.
That's why what we're going to talk about today is actually a
good thing.
And it's a good thing for all of us because I'm
not perfect.
The elders aren't perfect. You're not perfect.
And so we are all going to need correction at some
point, right?
We're all going to need accountability. We're all going to need
help toward living. The life. God has called us to live we
need each other in this journey, and I hope that
if you might have been wounded by something like this before.
And what you'll hear today is healing.
is
finding healing in as we look at what God actually says
and how we are to handle it that you find some measure
of Grace here.
What God really says so Titus 3 verses 9 through
11.
But avoid foolish controversies genealogies dissensions
and corals about the law.
For they are unprofitable and worthless.
as for a person who stirs up division
after warning him once and then twice have nothing more
to do with him.
Knowing that such a person is Warped and sinful.
He is self condemned.
God we need you as we've already said
over and over today. We need you.
To open our hearts and our minds to soften
our hearts to see and hear what you want us to see and
hear today.
Lead us.
Change us.
For Your Glory in Jesus name we pray
amen
Now if you remember back in titus's day on the island of
Crete there were false teachers trying to disrupt the
new church.
Bringing in all these false ideas disrupting the
gospel heresy things that didn't match
with God's word. And so so we already saw in
chapter one how Titus was to deal with them how he
was supposed to handle them and here he's just kind of repeating it
in a little bit different form. But what we see here
is it takes it actually a level deeper.
To those who might merely be caught up in all
that Ruckus.
That not only the false teachers, but now people within
the church were causing division as a result.
Or maybe they're they're causing other types of Divisions. We
don't know about but it's just that point of verse 10
as for a person who stirs that's that can
be any of us, right?
That's why we need one another.
To be a check in any drift in our
lives.
To guard one another from slipping into error wherever we might slip
into that to help keep one another from being known
as one who's stirring up division or or causing trouble
or being known as a sinful person. We don't want anyone
to be there.
but the reality is
the old man can reappear in a church.
The old man can reappear in a
church again. I'm not talking about age. We talked about this last week in
verse 3 that the old man is a description of the flesh
being in control of your life.
That's the old man we've talked
about and you see a contrast in verses 1
through 3 here of the new man that we're
supposed to be in Christ. But also the old man is explained versus
one through three says remind them to be
submissive to rulers authorities. Be obedient be
ready for every good work to speak
evil of no one avoid quarreling be gentle show perfect
courtesy toward all people. That's the new
man verse 3 for we ourselves were
once foolish.
disobedient LED astray
slaves to various passions and Pleasures passing our days and Malice
and envy hated by others hating one another. That's
the old man.
But that is why we get what we get in the passage today,
right that someone who's led by the flesh the
old man instead of submission to
Authority you get Disobedience dissension
and divisions.
Because what was happening back then is that these people love to
stir up trouble. They were they were talking and debating about
foolish discussions spiritual pedigrees. They
were talking about who was more more faithful
closer to God based on your family lineage.
Like we're more Jewish than you are even though we're Christians.
We're still closer to God.
debates and discussions divisions
and you saw in chapter three verses 1 and
2 you're supposed to avoid coraling and you're not quarrel
somebody instead of that as the old man is in charge you get foolish controversies.
You get rampant fighting about back. Then the
tiny nuances of Jewish law and nitpicking where
somebody was just one degree off and and you're off and
you're out and and it was debating less important
issues. And that's what they loved.
They love the drama.
That they saw whenever they stirred stuff up.
They fed off of it.
And so instead of the new life in Christ, where where you're
to be stunned by the gospel ready for good
works. These people were living like the old
man.
Verses 9 through 11 is a picture again of what the
old man looks like.
And that was happening because verse 3 said they were LED astray.
The way verse 11 says it they were in sin. They were
warped.
Not like Mario gets warped like it was warped in
the sense that word means off track like someone on
a train and trains derailing and running off
down into the valley. That's what's happened to these people.
They've been LED astray.
And before you think this was only a problem 2,000 years ago
in pre-increte.
These same kinds of divisive problems show
up regularly in churches even today.
I heard just a couple weeks ago of a church in Oklahoma that is
splitting because the pastor's wife was berating women
who worked outside the home.
That their blaspheming God somehow.
or think of how some Churches may not ever say it
out loud, but sure act like one ethnicity is more
valuable to God than any other ethnicity is
or think of how quickly
divisions happen over preferences in a
church
Whether it's clothing choices or music style or
how active to be politically or not.
now
I want to be clear that there are some things we're going to fight for.
That we are going to stand on and and
hold fast to like the core elements of the Gospel
what God's word reveals as truth. There
are Hills worth dying on.
but in everything else
instead of fighting one another
we are to fight for Unity.
We are to hold Loosely what God's word holds this loosely?
And don't think that's impossible to walk in unity,
even with diverse and different opinions and all kinds of different things.
It's possible because remember Ephesians 2 describes Jews
and Gentiles were able to
be in the church together.
The most opposite hated people were able to
be in the church together. If they could that means we most certainly
can.
But what it took for them?
to get to that
was what we refer to as higpuff.
Ephesians 4:2 is where that comes from higpuff humility gentleness,
patience and forbearance.
That's what it took for Jews and Gentiles to
be in the church together. It's the same thing for us eager to
maintain the unity of the spirit in the
bond of peace.
That's what it takes.
to walk in unity together
now in all this talk of unity divisions
I don't want you to walk away from this.
Thinking that you can never ask a question of leaders.
That you can never bring up an issue because you're going to be labeled as
a divisive person. That is not at all what we're talking about
because we know we're gonna make mistakes.
We know that you need Clarity on things that are happening. Yes, and
so come talk to us about it. Absolutely. We want to
talk about it what Titus 3:9
is talking about is a divisive spirit.
different right
where somebody is walking around teaching heresy in
active opposition to The Stance of God's word
and that's that's divisive Spirit or
or just fighting over trivial things.
Like my mom used to say it making a mountain out of a molehill anybody ever
heard that one before?
Right. It's a small it's not a big deal and you make
it this massive issue.
Here's why James 4:1 actually ties
it to the old man within us.
That flesh. That's still there says what causes corals and
fights among you is it not that
your passions are at War within you?
What is the passion that's the old man? That's the flesh
creeping back up and say no. No, you should
want this. This should be yours, and it's causing corals
and fights.
That was Paul's whole point in saying what he said to Titus here. He
says do these things to protect the
church.
To protect the church to protect the church's Mission
because what the the Lost out there would see
in this church in Crete was unity
and they were like man that seems radical to
me. I want what you have but if they saw disunity they
saw factions and breaking it all apart. They would
look at it and say see you guys can't even get along.
Come on.
This is thing real.
So Paul was saying Titus protect the church Titus protect
the church's mission.
That's why we must lean toward Unity lean
toward togetherness.
Not purposely looking for ways to distinguish in
ways to divide.
fighting over this and that
leaving churches for trivial things.
Second Timothy 2:14 says quarrels like
that. It says ruins the hearers.
We can't forget what this is causing.
Now again, let me be clear. There are absolutely valid reasons
to leave a church.
Like if you start smelling heresy from the the pulpit, yeah.
If you see the lifestyles of the leadership not matching up
what Titus one said the qualifications should be yeah.
If no one is addressing sin in members' lives.
Yeah.
If no one is making effort as Leaders to care
for the flock and just say forget you they yeah, of course
and there's probably many more reasons.
But so much of what has triggered the Sheep
shuffling of our day has little
to do with those things and way more to do with preferences.
Or an unwillingness to do the hard
things like have conversations and come to an understanding
about something you're different over.
Or even just your apathy and
your lack of involvement and so you start to drift but you
blame the church.
Don't let bitterness creep into your heart
where you just start looking for problems.
Instead in the truth of God's word look
for ways to be Unified.
Look for ways to foster togetherness look for ways
to work together as one body because one
of the primary ways the enemy attacks any church is
when any of us let this old man
creep back in and have control.
That's when division happens.
You start looking out for number one instead of looking out for what God wants.
Titus was supposed to and we are supposed to Major on
the sound Doctrine from verse 1
remember that produces this Godly living. He tied
us was supposed to focus there.
Same with us.
Says that is excellent and profitable verse 8.
Not what here, it says these unprofitable worthless
things that just divide us.
So Paul says to Titus here's what you are to avoid.
in verse 9
But then he says here's what you do with it. Here's what you do with this
old man when he or she creeps back up in the church. What do
you do Titus you warn them?
Here's what you do Titus avoid it stay away
from it. Don't get caught up in that mess. But here's what you do when you see it.
You warn them.
Whether that false teachers proclaiming heresy you go
after that you warn them or if it's somebody who's
just caught up in sin and we'll see where we go with that how to get
caught up in sin. Yeah you are to warn that's what verse 10 says as
for a person who stirs up division after warning him
once and then twice have nothing more to do
with them.
Pretty straightforward, right?
Most commentators agree that what Paul's doing here is he's just
explaining and applying what Jesus said
back in Matthew 18.
This is what Jesus said in Matthew 18 verses 15
through 17. See if it starts to sound familiar. Now.
Jesus said if your brother sins against you
go and tell him his fault between you and him
alone if he listens to you you've gained your brother.
But if he does not listen take one or two, others along
with you.
That every charge may be established by the evidence of two or
three Witnesses. If he refuses to listen to them tell
it to the church. If you refuse to listen even to the
church let him be to you as a gentile and a
tax collector.
Sounds a lot like Titus 3, right?
Well, here's what's happened with this passage in Matthew 18, though.
Sadly it has been used to create some
rigid structure of coldly confronting sin.
Where it has seemed like the goal is to kick people
out of the church.
But does that smell like the
Redemptive Spirit of Jesus in any
way?
especially
especially since right before this passage the Jesus tells a
parable of seeking the lost sheep.
And then right after this passage he talks about how many times you're supposed
to forgive somebody 70 times 7.
And sandwiched in between somehow we got into this thing.
Like we're gonna work through this really quickly and and we're gonna
be excited to go after somebody and call out their sin
and so we can get him out of the church.
It doesn't match right?
It's the spirit of the text. Is he saying no, like second Thessalonians
3:15. Do not regard him as an enemy
warn him as a brother.
Again, the whole point of this is good.
It's for our good.
Because the goal is that someone listens Matthew 18 says
that means they repent their relationship
is restored.
By the way, when we say the word repent around here, here's what
we mean.
Literally in the text means turning away from
something turning to something a change of mind.
We would just say it shorthand seeking to change.
When you hear the word repentance, it should not trigger. It
doesn't mean just saying you're sorry for what you did.
Right. That's that's just I'm sorry.
It's not repentance.
And that's it's not also just acknowledging that it happened.
Right. Yeah.
I did it.
It's also here this one.
It's also not just saying you're sorry for them
feeling the way they do.
You got that?
I'm sorry, you feel that way.
That's not owning anything. Right? No when we say repentance.
We say I did that. I hate it.
I'm so sorry. I did it.
God help me change you help me change.
You see the difference?
Not just I'm sorry. Sorry you feel that way? Yeah, I
know that hurt.
that hurts that
I know I did. I'm sorry.
Can you help me change God help me change? I
don't want that anymore.
That's a whole different mindset when we
talk about Matthew 18 listening repentance.
In fact in Matthew 18. There's even a Step
Zero that Jesus assumes here, but we
we can't forget.
It's the conviction that God's spirit brings when
you're by yourself.
He jumps immediately too when somebody sends against you you go to
them that kind of thing. No, it's when you're by yourself and and think about that if
if God's spirit convicts you and it it ends it
right there. If you repent right God shows you
your own sin. You repent and nobody else even though you're done.
Because here's the thing. Listen if God's at work in
your life if his spirit is at work in your life.
He will not let you be comfortable with sin.
He won't let you continue on as if it's okay.
You're eventually going to start feeling what I felt for a
season in my time years ago.
What Psalm 32 verses three
and four describes?
It says when I kept silent my bones
wasted away.
Through my groaning all day long.
For day and night your hand. God was Heavy upon me.
My strength was dried up as by The Heat Of
Summer.
Not gonna ask you to raise your hand, but you you feel that before right?
So God's not going to let you be comfortable with sin.
But the reality is some of us get stuck at times, don't we?
We get stuck.
times of Shame
when we don't want
to get caught
we don't want to get exposed in what we're doing because we
know what that's going to do to reputation. There's no
I don't want to tell anybody because I know what's gonna come on the other side of it. And so
what we do is we stuff it in the closet of our hearts and and
we hope nobody finds out and we think and we deceive ourselves
that we can manage it and we can keep it back there
and we can make sure nobody gets hurt by it, but I can just keep it
here for a while.
That's why Jesus said what he said in Matthew 18.
Because at some point we are all going
to need.
Some help to walk out of the darkness into the light.
We can deceive ourselves, but we got to have somebody walking
into it.
with us
Okay, so what do you do?
What do you do when your sin against?
or
Titus 3 what happens when somebody has a device of spirit you see
it? You notice it you understand it. What do you do?
Well first you go to them individually to warn them.
So what it says, right you warn them individually of
sins consequences if you continue this
track, here's what's
coming
It's what Jesus said tell him his fault between you and him
alone.
Hear me. This is not getting one of the pastors to
do it for you.
This is not getting your CG leader to do it for you.
Right. Hey, did you hear what he's doing? You need to go talk
to him about that? No, if you know you go.
If it's against you you go if if it's something you see happen
you go.
Now you don't go in a judgmental way.
You go in a humble and self-aware kind
of way like you're recognize your own failures too.
And you're going to them humbly in it. I love how Jesus said
this. This is one of the most profound images you can ever have in your mind.
The way Jesus said this is you take the log out
of your eye so you can help them with the speck of
dust in their eye.
So just think about this.
He's saying don't walk around like
this.
And you're walking up to somebody and you're saying to
the hey, hey, I noticed you've got this this issue
that I had confronted and and and and
you you turn in smack him in the face with a log in your eye
and they're you're trying to talk to them. You can't even see to get
the speck out of there. That's what he's saying.
He's saying get this thing out of here so you can see clearly to
help them.
Don't walk around blinded by your own sin. Trying
to help somebody else with theirs.
No, you walk humbly. You acknowledge your
own sin that you could get there to Galatians 6
says it. Well, if anyone's caught in any transgression you who
are spiritual should restore him in a spirit of gentleness,
but keep watch on yourself lest you
to be tempted.
Yes, help them but watch yourself.
As you bear one of those burdens and fulfill the law of Christ.
And so there's an individual warning there's this humble self-aware
help.
And the goal would be again for it to stop right there
that you've gained your brother. Jesus says that means
they've repented their Desiring to walk on God's pathway again.
You don't want it to go. Any farther right sin is not
good for anyone.
If you're trying to keep it managed that thing's gonna break open
that door at some point at the worst time.
And it's gonna destroy you in many others if you keep stuffing it
as we'll see we don't want it to go further. We
want that immediate repentance right there. It's done.
Sadly, it doesn't always work out. That way. Does it?
Sometimes they refuse to listen.
To many conversations you have with them and it's
over and over and over again, or they start pushing back on you.
At least to The Next Step that we go with another.
That's what Jesus said we go with another.
Again, the goal is to keep the circle as small as possible.
That you're not gossiping about this like
you're not sharing a prayer request about that person.
That's not part of this deal.
But you care enough about them not to let them go. So you
take one or two with you you take objective observers with
you to have further conversations with it. So
that's not you getting your cronies together to go gang up on the person if
the idea is that you both might be
seeing this and correctly.
You both might be misunderstanding something because we want
to be sure in this process that what we're addressing is
actually a Biblical sin issue.
not preference
Hey Brother listen
I mean the guys we saw you.
so you're wearing a brown belt with black pants and
Listen, we're gonna need to go through your closet with
you. No, right.
You might need to go with them to the store,
but I'm saying that's not a thin issue.
I know it's silly. But listen.
How often do we start to creep
into those personal preference and conviction issues
ourselves? That's not biblical.
And we say that's a sin issue and we start to divide over that
and call people out over that that's not what we're talking about here. We're talking
about.
sin issues in God's word
And as you bring someone with you Clarity comes to
the situation you both understand things a little bit.
But hopefully also if somebody comes with you that that person begins to
see how big a deal this sin really is.
You can say to them look brother. This is this is right
here you're doing this and it's dangerous if you
keep this track and somebody else is with you.
Again, you're praying the whole time that this would be the end that it stops
there that they repent they finally realize this is something I need
to turn from their heart changes. They make it
right with the person. They've hurt all of those things and it's
over.
Sadly doesn't always work out that way, right?
Sometimes they continue refusing to listen or they push back even
harder on things or what happens they run off from from you
and the church leads to the last piece here. You warn
them as a church.
You warn them as a church and just like that first step that previous step probably
had multiple iterations. You're trying to win their heart. You're multiple conversations
over and over again. But in this case at this
point again trying to keep the circle as small as
possible. We don't just blast it out on an email. You probably first
come to the elders and we make that intentional
effort we go to them and we try to talk with
them about what's going on. But but really here's the
truth at this point in the journey.
That person's often so hard-hearted. They'll refuse to listen to anybody.
Even if the whole church would know.
Even the whole church was pleading and praying and and calling
for repentance from blatant sin. There's no change in
their heart.
That's why Jesus said it at the end of Matthew 18 is 17
if he refuses to listen even to the church. Let him be to
you as a gentile and a tax collector.
The way Paul said in Titus 3 was to have nothing more
to do with him knowing such a person's warped sinful self
condemned.
Galatians 5 19 through 21 says comprehensively. This
is not just big sins but everything persisting
in that if you are led by the
flesh The Works of the flesh are evident.
sexual morality impurity sensuality idolatry sorcery
enmity strife
jealousy fits of anger rivalries dissensions
divisions
Envy drunkenness orgies things like
these I warn you as I warned you before those who
do and that we're do as a continual doing marked
by such things will not inherit
the kingdom of God.
so
if someone refuses to repent over blatant sin
being warned over and over through tears,
we are to treat them as
if they are an unbeliever.
That's what Jesus said Gentile and tax collector. That's the phrase used often
for those who are outside the faith. He's talking
about being an unbeliever because jesus' goal
is the same as Paul's. Jesus said I want to protect the church.
Want to give a pure picture of the
church to the world Unity within the church to the
world. I want to protect it.
But listen, I don't want you to miss something really really important here.
Because I remember how I started this whole thing.
We assume.
That in a believer's life. The holy spirit is at work.
Right. Holy spirit planted in you and belief. We assume
that a Believer has the Holy Spirit working in
them. So if you continue to refuse
the call to repentance over
and over pleading with you to turn we have
to wonder if the holy spirit is in there.
now
we don't know.
We're not able to declare whether someone's a Believer or not.
That's God's deal. That's between that person and God,
but what we do believe is that the Holy Spirit Will
convict of sin.
The holy spirit will lead towards righteousness. Even if you have
to use other people to get us there he will do it.
And so hear me, we're not in any way declaring someone an
unbeliever in this process.
They've just self-identified as one.
As Titus 3:11. He says he is self condemned.
Based on the way that their life track has gone.
Jesus says treat them as an unbeliever because it
seems like they are.
Now, I know this all seems kind of harsh.
But there's a question we often miss at that point.
It's something I think.
It's critical and all this when you look at all of what scripture says.
How are we to treat unbelievers?
Scriptures very clear that we are to love them.
We are to care for them.
We are to pray for them.
We are to preach the gospel to them.
We just are not to be unequally yoked.
with unbelievers
means we don't share with them the things
that are reserved for the faith family.
This is General truth that you should be the closest with
fellow Believers not with unbelievers.
Those should be your closest friends as believers.
Now for somebody in this stage of life that
state you should be there when their life falls apart. Absolutely.
but if they've gotten to that point you've done all that you
can
it's God's work.
He has to change a heart.
They're actually hoping this.
Because our stories throughout church history of members of churches who
are deceived by the enemy caught up in sin. They they
got confronted over the sin. They ran away
accused the Church of judgmentalism. You guys are just being stuck up
all of those things one day though.
As they wandered through the desert of their life.
God wooed their heart back to him.
and and
Suddenly, they saw those people who had come after them in
their sin before.
Not as judgmental, but is actually loving.
That factor cared for me.
They saw that I was doing this and they came after me they confronted sin
in my life. But that actually meant they cared
they loved and they remembered Jesus in that.
So yes all this is hard.
It may seem impossible. Someone's gotten this far to change but does not
have to be the end of their story.
It doesn't have to be the end of your story either because you remember
the gospel.
You remember what got the gospel that we saw in Titus 3 verses 3
through 5 last week that we are selves were
once foolish disobedient LED astray slaves to
various passions and Pleasures passing our days and Malice and
envy hated by others hating one another.
but
when the goodness and loving kindness of God our savior
appeared he saved us not because of Works done by
us and righteousness. But according to his own Mercy by
the washing of regeneration and renewal of the Holy Spirit.
See the reality here is that this old man? We've
been talking about can be a new man.
Right, the old man does not have to be who you are. It doesn't
mean you have to stay the way you are. He's an old man can
be a new man in Christ.
And that's possible. Listen that's possible for the worst sinner,
you know in your life.
that woman you look at and say
she's the like that it's possible for her.
that's possible for
the church member who's grown up playing a religious game their whole
life.
is possible even
for you
But what it takes.
It takes Brokenness. It takes repentance. It
takes setting aside the fear of what other people think.
Listen, I know.
I know from my own experience that there are many people in this room
today who are hiding sin.
Who are walking in this this internal
embarrassment over what you've been doing and you
know it and you don't want to tell anyone yet. You're
putting on a smile and you're playing the part.
Can I tell you something?
Stop it.
just stop
don't you want to walk in the freedom that Christ
has purchased for you?
Instead of hiding back here and chained up don't you
want to walk in that freedom? I know it's terrifying to
think of exposing that to your loved one
or to a friend.
I know that sick feeling in your stomach right
now you think about even doing that?
I know how terrifying it is because you don't know what's gonna
come on the other side of that. How are they going to respond? You have? No, it's scary.
Absolutely. It is but hear me you should
be way more concerned about how you respond to God than what
that feels like.
He sees it all anyway.
You're not hiding.
Yet don't forget this.
The best part is that he knew you were gonna do it.
Any new you're gonna hide it.
And yet he died for you on the cross anyway.
He knew it was coming.
and you as his enemy he looked at you and said
I want you my family.
Open your hands up.
Open your hands get rid of this acts 3:19
says repent and return that your sins
may be wiped away. In order that times of
refreshing may come to
your soul.